in Deutschland wurde am Sonntag gefeiert
die meisten der Menschen die hier für
die Türkei wählen durften die haben ihr
Kreuz bei Erdogan gemacht Bundeskanzler
Scholz hat den Präsidenten schon nach
Berlin eingeladen der Nato-Partner
Türkei spielt eine wichtige Rolle in der
Auseinandersetzung mit Russland und auch
beim Thema Flüchtlinge Erdogans Wahlsieg
wie umgehen mit der Türkei unser Thema
in der phönix-runde
guten Abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin das sind meine Gäste Armin
Laschet ist uns zugeschaltet Mitglied
des Bundestags für die CDU und auch
Mitglied des Auswärtigen Ausschusses und
er ist viel zu Präsident der
Parlamentarischen Versammlung des
Europarates und dort gehört die Türkei
auch dazu er war Kanzlerkandidat
Vorsitzender der CDU Ministerpräsident
in Nordrhein-Westfalen und dort war ja
auch der erste Integrationsminister des
Landes ich begrüße Holo er ist
Bundesvorsitzender der türkischen
Gemeinde in Deutschland das ist ein
überparteilicher verband er selbst hat
für die Opposition gestimmt und ist
SPD-Mitglied und herzlich willkommen er
ist Rechtsanwalt und Pressesprecher der
UID United international demokrats das
ist die Auslandsvertretung der AKP also
der Partei Erdogans und die UID früher
die wird von deutschen Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet herzlich willkommen Christina
Dunst stellvertretende Leiterin der
Hauptstadt Redaktion des
redaktionsnetzwerks Deutschland
in Deutschland haben viele Menschen
gefeiert 67 Prozent haben für Erdogan
gestimmt der Menschen die hier wählen
durften wie haben sie das Wahlergebnis
aufgenommen
ja spannend war das auf jeden Fall im
Vorfeld weil nach den Umfragen Kopf an
Kopf Rennen war was eigentlich bei mir
schon drei Tage oder vier Tage vorher
ihr ein anderes Gefühl rausgekommen ist
das ist doch sehr knapp wird und knapp
auf ihrem für Eltern sowas auch ich
denke es ist ein Prozent geworden erste
Wahlgang war ja erstmal dass er nicht
gewonnen hat ist es glaube ich erst das
muss man auch anmerken das ist eine Wahl
die Erdogan nicht gewonnen hat gleich
beim ersten Rundgang bei der zweite
Durchgang hatte gepunktet und hatte die
Wahl gewonnen die muss man einfach
gratulieren und sehen sich jetzt
optimistisch und die Zukunft für die
Türkei weil sie selber haben ja die
Opposition unterstützt
ich denke ich habe natürlich gewählt
aber bei mir geht es eher darum wie ich
das Leben hier in Deutschland weitergeht
für uns weil das Leben für uns
spielt hier und ich denke das sind viel
wichtiger Aspekte dass wir uns jetzt
immer schauen wie es uns in Deutschland
geht und wirst Deutschland allgemein
geht das ist für mich ausschlaggebend
und darüber was in der Türkei passiert
da werden die Türken und die türkische
Politiker und Politikerinnen entscheiden
okay darüber reden wir natürlich gleich
noch ausführlich Herr Laschet Präsident
Erdogan also weitere fünf Jahre im Amt
was bedeutet das dieses Ergebnis für die
Zusammenarbeit Deutschlands mit der
Türkei
das bedeutet zunächst dass es keinen
Kurswechsel gibt dass die
Bundesregierung mit jemandem
zusammenarbeiten muss den man seit 20
Jahren kennt in seinen unterschiedlichen
Phasen und ich denke es war ein
richtiges Signal dass der Bundeskanzler
direkt gesagt hat ich lade den neu
gewählten türkischen Präsidentin ein
nach Berlin zum Antrittsbesuch um jetzt
zu überlegen wie wir den
deutsch-türkischen Beziehungen eine neue
Dynamik geben können so hat er es
ausgedrückt und ich halte diese
Einschätzung und diesen Weg des
Bundeskanzlers für richtig und was wäre
denn eine neue Dynamik
ja gut das fängt ja mit es gibt ja viele
Themen die jetzt zu lösen sind
wir wissen alle dass das
flüchtlingsabkommen endet in wenigen
Wochen darüber wird man erneut sprechen
müssen wie können wir die Türkei
weiterhin dabei unterstützen die
Flüchtlinge aus Syrien im Lande
aufzunehmen das ist ja einer der Dinge
die ihn unterscheiden von dem
Oppositionsführer der
aktivstimmung und Hetze gegen
Flüchtlinge gemacht hat der gesagt hat
er will 10 Millionen in kürzester Zeit
aus dem Lande bringen und das mit Assad
vereinbaren
das wird jetzt bei Erdogan sicher in
dieser Form nicht geschehen aber die
flüchtlingsthematik wird eine wichtige
bleiben auch im Verhältnis zur
Europäischen Union das zweite wichtige
Thema das morgen schon auf dem Gipfel
der Außenminister der Natur beraten wird
ist die Mitgliedschaft Schwedens in der
NATO da hat die Türkei bisher Vorbehalte
angemeldet
und ich erwarte dass es bis Juli bis zum
Gipfel in Vilnius gelingen könnte dass
die Türkei ihr Veto aufgibt und einer
Aufnahme Schwedens in die NATO zustimmt
und das dritte wichtige Thema ist
natürlich aber darüber werden wir
vielleicht im Laufe der Sendung ja noch
sprechen die mittlere Rolle die die
Türkei im Krieg mit der Ukraine
eingenommen hat es ist ja bemerkenswert
dass sowohl Präsident selensky als auch
Putin
Erdogan gratuliert haben er hat das
getreideabkommen mit ermöglicht dass die
Verkehre des Getreides durch den
Bosporus in die Länder des Südens
ermöglicht also hier wird er sicher
weiter eine wichtige Rolle spielen und
wird da auch ein wichtiger
Ansprechpartner für Deutschland sein es
egal wie sehen sie es weil es gab jetzt
durchaus so das gibt durchaus natürlich
viele kritische Stimmen in Richtung
Erdogan es ist ein autokratisches System
die Pressefreiheit ist nicht die die wir
spricht nicht unseren Standard viele
positionelle sitzen auch im Gefängnis
also was wie sehen Sie es wie könnte
sich das verändern wird das ein noch
autokratischeres Regime mit mehr Druck
noch für Oppositionelle also ich finde
dass Herr Laschet das Gut skizziert hat
also da wo wir unseren Fokus darauf
lenken sollten ist was bedeutet die
Wiederwahl Herrn Erdogans nach 21 Jahren
an der Macht so ein Ergebnis zu erzielen
verdient erstmal Respekt und Anerkennung
was bedeutet das für Deutschland und
insbesondere für Europa und diese drei
großen Themenblöcke das sind die
Themenblöcke mit dem wir uns jetzt
beschäftigen müssen Stichwort
flüchtlingsabkommen in der Tat ist das
aus europäischer Sicht eigentlich ein
gutes Wahlergebnis was das
flüchtlingsabkommen anbelangt weil wir
da auf Kontinuität hoffen können während
alle anderen Kandidaten und Parteien
tatsächlich das flüchtlingsthema zur
zentralen zum zentralen Wahlkampf Thema
gemacht haben hat Herr Erdogan immer von
Brüder und Schwestern geredet die man
nicht einfach so wegschicken können und
was das Thema Flüchtlinge anbelangt da
weiß ich ganz genau der Autor der
Ministerpräsident seiner Zeit der hat
der den sogenannten flüchtlingsstil
sozusagen geschlossen und ich habe kurz
danach mit Herrn Erdogan sprechen können
und er war nicht sehr erfreut über
diesen flüchtlingsstil und hat nach wie
vor den flüchtlingsdeal eingehalten das
muss man konzentrieren das ist das eine
Thema trotzdem war noch mal meine Frage
danach nachdem nach der Entwicklung des
Landes und was es bedeutet für die
Menschen die oppositionelle sind und die
auch deshalb in dem Gefängnis sitzen
naja Herr Erdogan hat selber nach der
Wahl gesagt dass die ganze Türkei
gewonnen hat das heißt wir hatten jetzt
ein Wahlkampf der Wahlkampf der war
nicht so heftig wie man ihn aus
Wahlkämpfen vorangegangener waren sehen
konnte zu mal natürlich auch die
schreckliche Erdbebenkatastrophe
unmittelbar zuvor im Februar sich eignet
hat und jetzt ist die Wahl vorbei das
heißt jetzt kann man davon ausgehen dass
sozusagen auch ähm das Volk befriedet
wird oder die zentralen Wahlkampf Themen
vorbei sind und dass die Türkei jetzt
ihren Weg gehen wird insbesondere die
wirtschaftliche Situation Funktion im
Lande zu verbessern und auf Themen wie
Digitalisierung Fortschritt und vor
allen Dingen auch
soziopolitische Komponenten ihrer
Akzente zu setzen Frau Dunst wie sehen
Sie das wenn Sie jetzt die verschiedenen
Stimmen hören wenn man sieht wie sollte
Deutschland wie geht Deutschland denn
mit diesem Ergebnis um der Bundeskanzler
hat er dann schon eingeladen wie wichtig
ist die Türkei jetzt auch nach diesem
Wahlsieg als Partner die Türkei war ist
und bleibt ein wichtiger Partner ich
würde nur gerne auf die anderen 48%
verweisen die nicht zu den
Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützern von
Präsident Erdogan gehören und deswegen
der Sieg klar eine Gratulation ist
selbstverständlich nur es ist eben ein
sehr sehr knapper Sieg und da sollten
wir nicht vergessen welche unglaubliche
Enttäuschung bei den Anhängern der
Opposition da ist und bei einer sehr
sehr großen Gruppe in dem Land und wenn
sie sagen er hat es klar geworden würde
ich sagen er hat es sehr knapp gewonnen
und daraus befürchte ich schon
Konsequenzen auch weil das für ihn nach
meiner Einschätzung ziemlicher Schock
ist dass das so knapp war und er wird
glaube ich versuchen wollen das zu
zementieren dass seine Macht nicht
angegriffen wird und ich finde nicht
dass es ein so fairer Wahlkampf war sie
haben gesagt andere waren heftiger aber
so wie
Oppositionelle im Gefängnis gelandet
sind wie Journalisten behandelt werden
wie Herr Erdogan sich präsentieren
konnte auch in den Staatsmedien habe ich
das Gefühl dass die Opposition dort
nicht mit gleichen ja Möglichkeiten
Wahlkampf machen konnte wie Erdogan also
wohl wahr sein
mir also die Wahl war frei aber fair war
das auf keinen Fall und ich habe
dasselbe an eigenen Leibe erlebt als ich
selber zwei Tage lang krank war habe ich
mir noch zusätzlich gegönnt mal diese
öffentlich-rechtliche Fernseher oder die
von von der Regierung kontrollierte
Medien anzuschauen um überhaupt so die
Stimmung mit zu bekommen und wenn man
wirklich 12 Stunden am Tag Erdogan in
den Bildern in dem Fernseher sieht egal
was er tut wird er wurde ja live
übertragen hat man nicht das Gefühl
gehabt dass in der Türkei eine
Opposition ein Kandidaten hat man hat es
entweder in eine gewisse die Vermehrung
mitbekommen und auch erdogan hat ja sehr
viel nie selber weg Informationen selber
verbreitet so dass er ein ein
Fake Video in bei der Kundgebung
Istanbul vor eins eine Millionen 700.000
Menschen gezeigt hat und das gleiche
noch mal im staatlichen Fernsehen also
von Fernitz kann man natürlich nicht
reden aber der hat bedeutet natürlich
auch eine soziale Medien eine große
Rolle gespielt in der Türkei aber die
Wahlen waren frei und die muss man
natürlich voneinander trennen hier haben
die Menschen halt eben mit großer mehr
mit zwei Drittel Mehrheit für Erdogan
bestimmt Herr Laschet der
Landwirtschaftsminister Jam Özdemir hat
getwittert der von den Grünen er hat die
autokorses und feiern hier in
Deutschland nach dem Wahlsieg er hat uns
hat er bezeichnet als Absage an unsere
pluralistische Demokratie und Zeugnis
unseres Scheiterns unter ihnen also ist
diese hohe Zustimmung unter den
deutschstöcken hier ist das Ergebnis
einer gescheiterten Integrationspolitik
ja das kommt dann immer das kenne ich
seit vielen Jahren wenn einem was nicht
passt ist gescheiterte
Integrationspolitik erstmal muss man die
Zahlen mal zurechtrücken das haben mich
67% der in Deutschland lebenden Türken
Erdogan gewählt sondern es hat sich
überhaupt nur die Hälfte an diesen
Wahlen beteiligt und wenn man das auf
die Türkei stämmigen Menschen in
Deutschland umrechnet sind es ca 17 bis
20 %. 1
wenn zwei Kandidaten zur Wahl stehen und
Menschen wählen den einen finde ich es
nach einer Wahl
nicht hilfreich dann zu sagen ja die
sind alle nicht integriert die haben es
alle nicht verstanden Wähler
Beschimpfung nach Wahlen sind immer
schlecht viele hätten sich ein anderes
Ergebnis gewünscht gerade in Deutschland
aber wenn Menschen zwischen zwei
Personen sich so entscheiden finde ich
haben wir das nicht negativ zu bewerten
und erst recht nicht denen die eine
andere Meinung gehabt haben als die die
man selbst hat dann zu unterstellen sie
seien nicht integriert in Deutschland
das ist nicht gut sie wissen dass ich
sonst mir sehr schätze mit ihm
befreundet bin aber in dieser
Wahrnehmung nach einer Wahl das halte
ich für falsch und das dritte dann haben
manche gesagt ja warum machen die solche
autokorsus
na gut also wenn wir die Bundestagswahl
gewonnen hätten wären die CDU-Anhänger
nicht mit Deutschland fahren durch die
Städte gefahren das macht man bei uns
eher nicht aber in der Türkei ist das
scheinbar so üblich dass man auf diese
Weise so feiert ich finde auch das kann
man mal einen Abend ertragen
ungewöhnlich ist es aber kein Grund
jetzt eine neue Integrationsdebatte in
Deutschland zu beginnen
sie ist das wird das zu wird das falsch
bewertet Unterstützung von hier
also ich gebe Herrn Laschet recht wenn
er dann sagt wir sollten jetzt nicht
wählerschelte betreiben ja also die Wahl
hat stattgefunden und circa zwei Drittel
haben sich für Herrn Erdogan
ausgesprochen zwei Dritteln der
Wahlberechtigten und genau diese
Argumentation von Herrn Laschet da muss
ich ihn teilweise widersprechen die ist
ja nicht neu die hatten wir bei den
vorangegangenen Wahlen auch als die in
Deutschland lebenden Türken wählen
konnten dann wurden die Zahlen etwas
relativiert ja sind nur jeder Zweite ist
ja zur Wahl gegangen wir haben eine
kontinuierliche Steigerung der
Wahlbeteiligung man muss sich mal vor
Augen führen bei dieser Stichwahl waren
die Konsulat indem man wählen konnte 5
Tage geöffnet und in diesen fünf Tagen
sind die Menschen teilweise aus 200 km
Entfernung angereist und haben
stundenlang haben sie gewartet bis sie
wählen konnten das heißt das muss man
auch erstmal anerkennen das verdient
Respekt und ich glaube die Menschen die
dann halt so zur Wahl gegangen sind
verdienen auch diesen Respekt jetzt sagt
man ja das sind ja nicht alle Türken und
viele haben ja auch den deutschen Pass
aber ich glaube dass dieses Ergebnis
doch schon ein repräsentatives ist wenn
man sich vor Augen führt dass teilweise
auch innerhalb der Familien einige
Familienmitglieder ausschließlich die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft haben und
andere nur die Türkisch türkische und
wenn man jetzt sagt ja die die den
deutschen Pass nicht haben die sind so
integriert die interessiert
interessieren sich gar nicht für diese
Wahlen glaube ich da ist das ein Stück
weit auch ein Bild was wir zeichnen was
mit der Realität wenig zu tun hat wir
müssen akzeptieren es gibt Zuspruch und
dieser Zuspruch der hat auch
verschiedenste Gründe auf die man mit
Sicherheit gleich auch eingehen werden
ich finde die Frage sehr interessant
warum der Anteil der Unterstützer von
Präsident Erdogan in Deutschland
umgerechnet größer ist als in der Türkei
selbst und her dass die mir hat ja auch
die Frage aufgeworfen warum ein warum
BürgerInnen und bürgerdienen einem sehr
sehr demokratischen Staat leben von hier
aus warum ist mehr von hier aus sind die
Erdogan unterstützen als im eigenen Land
wo er ein einen sehr strengen ein sehr
auch autokratischen Kurs fährt und diese
Frage sehe ich auch bei Herrn Laschet
nicht beantwortet das finde ich wirklich
wäre mal zu ergründen warum das so ist
ich habe mir sagen ich
habe mir sagen lassen dass es eben und
dann sind wir wieder bei ihm bei ihrem
Thema doch eine Verbindung gibt dass sie
sich bei Erdogan vertreten und gesehen
fühlen was sie sich in Deutschland weil
sie über Jahrzehnte nicht so sich
zumindest nicht so anerkannt fühlten und
und da die Verbindung sehen und dann hat
es eben doch was mit der
Integrationspolitik und der Fähigkeit
unseres Landes unserer Bürger damit zu
tun sie zu integrieren oder nicht gibt
es da was nachzudenken
ja ich meine ersten kritisiert Frau
Dunst dass ich die Frage nicht
beantwortet habe die mir gar niemand
gestellt hat alles gut gestellt ist kann
ich dir natürlich auch gerne beantworten
kann ich dir gerne beantworten das
Phänomen also erdogan hat in der Türkei
gewonnen und hat in Deutschland die
meisten Stimmen aber er hat in
Deutschland Prozent Wahl mehr Stimmen
als in der Türkei woran liegt das das
ist ja dann die Fragestellung so ähm bei
den Deutschen die im Ausland wählen die
dürfen ja auch wählen jeder Deutsche auf
der Welt darf wählen kann man das nicht
feststellen wie die Leute wählen weil
man sich dann bei der letzten Stadt in
der man zuvor gewohnt hat
anmelden muss und da wählt man dann so
dass das Wahlergebnis verschwindet also
ob die Leute im Ausland die deutsche
sind eher konservativer wählen als im
Inland würde ich mal vermuten glaube ich
ist aber nicht belegbar und man kennt
das von vielen die jaspera Situationen
wenn sie Deutsche in Südamerika erleben
die leben in einem Deutschland Bild der
50er und 60er Jahre und würden
wahrscheinlich auch so abstimmen wenn
Sie das in breiter Form tun könnten das
ist der eine Teil meiner Antwort also
eine Diaspora lebt immer in einer
idealeren Vorstellung des Landes als die
Menschen die tagtäglich die
wirtschaftlichen Probleme die Frage der
Pressefreiheit der Menschenrechte oder
Ähnliches erleben und der zweite Teil
dafür Frau Dunst einen Punkt der bei
dieser Wahl geringer war als bei den
letzten Wahlen
ich erinnere daran dass vor einigen
Jahren noch Präsident Erdogan riesige
Kundgebungen in Deutschland gemacht hat
Kölnarena 20.000 Menschen wo man sich
gefragt hat wieso geht sowas eigentlich
und die Antwort ist ganz einfach es hat
selten ein deutscher Politiker ein
deutscher Bundeskanzler gesagt ich bin
auch der Kanzler der hier lebenden
Türkei ständigen Angela Merkel hat das
dann gesagt auch spätere
Bundespräsidentin haben das gesagt aber
das hat 50 Jahre gedauert Ehemann
wirklich den Menschen signalisiert hat
eure Probleme die ihr in Köln habt in
der Keupstraße habt in Mülheim habt in
Neuköln habt die kann nicht Präsident
Erdogan lösen die müssen hier in
Deutschland gelöst werden eure
Bildungschancen für eure Kinder eure
Integration der Kampf gegen
Diskriminierung gegen Rassismus das ist
ein deutsches Problem und insofern
glaube ich kann man schlussfolgern dass
wir uns noch stärker um diese starke
Gruppe in unserem Land kümmern müssen
und singen müssen wir deutschen
Politiker sind eure Vertreter sind eure
Ansprechpartner also dann doch das was
man sagt da gibt es noch sozusagen eine
Bringschuld wir haben am Wochenende
haben wir der dem Anschlag den
Brandanschlag in Solingen gedacht 30
Jahre ist das Herr Herr singer sie sind
mit der Familie Gensch befreundet sie
kommen aus Solingen das ist natürlich so
ein wirklicher Wendepunkt auch gewesen
und wenn man sieht nach 30 Jahren wie
stark dieses Ereignis noch spielt auch
gibt es ein Punkt wo sie sagen was ist
denn seitdem wirklich gut gelaufen das
was gut gelaufen ist ist die
Veranstaltung die gestrige Veranstaltung
in Solingen also man muss in der Tat
sagen Präsident Steinmeier war dabei
viele Minister waren dabei der
Ministerpräsident Nordrhein-Westfalens
war dabei und die haben alle eben das
was Herrschaft gerade eben angesprochen
hat erwähnt die haben gesagt wir sind
auch eure Vertreter und wir haben die
Fehler aus der Vergangenheit erkannt und
möchten jetzt auch nicht nur die
Probleme Beschreibung vollziehen sondern
auch die Behandlung angehen und das weiß
ich in der Tat zu schätzen und das haben
die Leute da auch in den Gesprächen die
ich im Nachhinein geführt habe auch
wirklich gewürdigt und es ist ein Punkt
wo wir uns überlegen müssen was sind die
was sind die Gründe gewesen die zu so
einem Brandanschlag geführt haben und
wir haben parallelen vielleicht nicht
die gleichen Asylpolitik Stichwort
damals ich will nicht zu weit in die
Vergangenheit gehen aber ein Satz ist
hängen geblieben es wurde gesagt es
passiert nicht das große böse auf einmal
von selbst sondern es bedarf vieler
kleiner Schritte die zum großen bösen
führen und ich glaube wir als
Gesamtgesellschaft deutsche Türken
gleichermaßen und alle die in der
deutschen Gesellschaft leben müssen sich
überlegen welchen Beitrag können wir
leisten damit es uns von allen in
Deutschland besser geht und damit es
eben nicht zu Problemen kommt und zu zu
rassistischen Anschlägen und
rassistischen aus Anfeindungen und
Diskriminierung kommt
da wir eine begrenzte Sendezeit haben
und noch so viele Themen und noch ein
bisschen nach vorne schauen wollen würde
ich gerne jetzt mal noch mal darauf
schauen was jetzt die Türkei wie wir wie
die Türkei ihren Platz in der EU oder in
Europa eben finden soll der Vorsitzende
der Europäischen Volkspartei Weber hat
gesagt wir sollten jetzt nach dem
Wahlsieg Erde ins Konsequenzen ziehen
und die Beitrittsverhandlungen der EU
mit der Türkei sollen gestoppt werden
was halten Sie denn davon
macht sich mit solchen Drohungen
eigentliche lächerlich weil der Faktor
die Verhandlungen der Zeit längere Zeit
gestoppt sind und gar nicht aufs Eis
gelegt worden sind und gar nicht darüber
diskutiert wird und das wird ja immer
wieder wenn es dann irgendwelche Krise
mit der Türkei gibt mit dem rausgeholt
falls ihr euch nicht benimmt dann werde
mir einfach diese Verhandlung nicht
fortführen davon sollte glaube ich ähm
Europa wegkommen das was vorher gesagt
hat man sollte auch mal den Menschen in
der Türkei die Hoffnung geben auch das
Gefühl Leben ihr gehört zu Europa man
muss einfach das Geld klar aussprechen
wenn man von 48 Prozent spricht aber
glaube ich auch dass er viele die Erde
an gewählt haben auch ein Wunsch habend
einen Teil der Europäischen Gemeinschaft
zu sein dass man das Gefühl den gibt den
Menschen gibt in der Türkei ihr gehört
hierher und deshalb kurz darauf
zurückzukommen geht das auch für die
Menschen die Deutsch dürfen hier das
gilt das ist auch so vielleicht mal ganz
kurz als wir uns zur verwandt gegründet
haben war kurz nach Mölln und Solingen
es waren unsere Sätze unsere Ansätze
dass wir uns erstmal Rassismus Probleme
in Deutschland auseinandersetzen das
andere war natürlich die Mitgliedschaft
der Türkei in der Europäische Union an
dem bleiben wir weiterhin weil wir
denken dass die Türkei
zu europäische Familie gehört natürlich
muss ich die Türkei auch reformieren
muss sie muss sich denken aber europa
muss auch klar sein dass der Türkei
jetzt nicht nur wenn es um
flüchtlingsstil geht dass man die Türkei
wichtig nimmt sondern das auch die
Türkei in abseher bereits seit Mitglied
der Europäischen Union wird
ganz kurz ergänzend ganz kurz nur ich
möchte Herrn ossopo zustimmen das ist
wirklich ein wesentlicher Punkt und wir
müssen glaube ich jetzt auch nach der
Wahl endlich lernen die Türkei auf
Augenhöhe zu betrachten das tun wir
nämlich nicht der fällt der fällt immer
der fällt immer aber er wird mich
praktiziert das heißt jetzt gab es ja
anscheinend dann halt diese
Verlautbarung wir müssen die Gespräche
auf Eis legen das hören wir auch
permanent das hat in der Vergangenheit
die Türkei nicht beeindruckend wird es
in Zukunft auch nicht tun konnte und was
ist das jetzt für ein Punkt dieser
erneute Wahrheit von Erdogan für das
Miteinander oder eben nicht miteinander
in die EU
also es gibt ja zwei Theorien die
Türkei hat sich unter Erdogan so
entwickelt weil alle Erwartungen
enttäuscht wurden dass es eben mit der
EU Mitgliedschaft mit dieser
Beitrittsperspektive nichts wurde dass
sie hingehalten wurde unter der früheren
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel wurde dann
die privilegierte Partnerschaft
ausgerufen auch das war ja so so
mitgliedsweiter klasse empfunden worden
in der in der Türkei und so wie die wie
die sich Erdogan entwickelt hat und wie
die Türkei jetzt verfasst ist also
Unterdrückung der Opposition eine eine
nicht wirklich unabhängige Justiz wäre
es schwierig wenn sie EU-Mitglied werden
würde ich finde nur man darf diese Tür
die man viel zu lange überhaupt nicht
richtig geöffnet hat 40 Jahre ich weiß
es nicht wie lange die Türkei darauf
wartet mit Blick wir haben es gerade
angesprochen mit Blick auf die gegen den
die große Gruppe der Verlierer dieser
Wahl also 48 Prozent sage ich mal und
sie sagen auch Erdogan Anhänger werden
dafür sein man darf sie man darf ihnen
das nicht vor der Nase zuschlagen und
das finden deswegen finde ich die
Bemühungen müssen weitergehen und man
hat die Türkei als ein ganz wichtigen
Nato-Partner und auch da muss man sich
sehr hart mit ihr mit ihm
auseinandersetzen ist was ganz anderes
aber
die Türkei und der Erdogan dürfen auch
nicht weiter in die Richtung von
Russland und China getrieben werden
sondern wir müssen versuchen Sie bei der
Union bei der Europäischen Union landet
also jetzt im Moment noch und viel
stärkeres ja also viel stärkere
Notwendigkeit die Türkei enger an die EU
zu binden was sagen sie denn ihrem
Parteikollegen Manfred Weber
er ist von der CSU aber gut
ich bin ich bin
obwohl ich ein enger Freund der Türkei
bin immer schon gegen eine
Vollmitgliedschaft gewesen das weiß auch
jeder nicht wegen der Türkei alleine
nicht weil wie das war früher mal die
Argumentation ja das sind ja Muslime die
EU ist christlich das dieses kulturelle
Argument ist Unsinn das teile ich nicht
aber wenn man leidenschaftlicher
Europäer ist darf man die Europäische
Union nicht überdehnen man muss sich
vorstellen wer Mitglied der Europäischen
Union ist für den gilt jeder einzelne
EU-Richtlinie 20.000 Vorschriften mit
einem Schlag im gesamten Gebiet und man
gibt alle Entscheidungen nach Brüssel ab
ich weiß gar nicht ob das jedem Anhänger
von Erdogan so klar ist dass demnächst
in Brüssel entschieden wird und nicht
mehr in Anker alle Gesetze des
Binnenmarktes entscheidet Brüssel
und ich glaube es würde das war immer
mein Argument in den letzten 20 Jahren
das würde die Europäische Union
überfordern wenn man ein so großes
Mitgliedsland einfach aufnehmen würde
daraus ist entwickelt worden die
privilegierte Partnerschaft alles öffnen
Binnenmarkt öffnen hochschulausgleich
öffnen vieles andere mehr das ist
verworfen worden das ist so wie verdunst
das gerade gesagt hat als Mitgliedschaft
zweiter Klasse bezeichnet worden für
Großbritannien werden wir uns jetzt so
etwas einfallen lassen müssen und warum
nicht einen Weg finden wo wir die Türkei
eng an Europa bindet dass meine
prinzipielle Meinung seit 20 Jahren aber
wir haben Kollege Weber gesagt hat passt
das Argument Weber dann haben sie ja
gefallen hast du überhaupt nicht also
mit diesen Wahlen hat dieses nun gar
nichts zu tun denn wir haben es ja
gerade schon gehört die Verhandlung sind
seit Jahren ausgesetzt mehrere andere
Mitgliedstaaten wie Frankreich müssten
eine Volksabstimmung machen wo jeder
weiß wie die ausgehen würde und deshalb
würde ich neue Wege in der Türkei suchen
aber nicht wegen dieses Wahlergebnis das
Wahlergebnis müsste er dazu führen dass
man sagt ja die 48 Prozent die auf jeden
Fall Richtung Europa wollen die dürfen
wir jetzt nicht alleine lassen ich finde
man muss es aus den beiderseitigen
Interessen aus den europäischen und aus
den türkischen zu einem ja wieder
Bundeskanzler gesagt hat zu einem neuen
Schwung nutzen ohne jetzt zum 20 30 50
mal die Frage zur eröffnen ob nun
beitrittsverhandlung gestoppt werden
oder nicht jetzt formell zu beenden
halte ich für falsch die sind in den
Prozess äh und der braucht seine Zeit
aber wenn Sie mir eine letzte bemerken
gestalten auch als Vizepräsident der
Parlamentarischen Versammlung des
europaweites da hat sich die Türkei
verpflichtet bestimmte Regeln
einzuhalten unter anderem
die Umsetzung von Gerichten des
Europäischen Gerichtshofes für
Menschenrechte das schmeckt den
Mitgliedsstaaten oft nicht auch
Deutschland muss da manchmal schlucken
bei diesen Urteilen aber es ist
entschieden dass Osman Kavala zu Unrecht
im Gefängnis sitzt Menschenrecht in der
Türkei in einer Institution man kann
nicht mit in einer Institution sein und
dann urteile nicht umsetzen und wenn wir
damals so weit sind dass die Regeln des
Europarates eingehalten werden dann kann
man über alles weitere sprechen dazu ist
im Moment gar kein anders wie wichtig
wäre es für die Opposition oder wie was
erwarten sie von der EU als als Stütze
für die Opposition in der Türkei
ich denke die Erwartung von EU ist schon
längst gar nicht mehr aktuell in der
Türkei weil man dieses vertrauende
gegenüber als Europäische Union schon
längst verloren hatte ist natürlich EU
im zuzwang wenn man die Türkei weiterhin
will dass die das EU sich bemühen soll
auf einer Seite auf der anderen Seite
ist natürlich hat der Laschet es recht
muss die Türkei sich auch bereit
erklären in diese Europäische Union
reinzukommen und das hat natürlich die
Voraussetzung was wie sieht die Türkei
entwickeln muss deswegen ist es sehr
wichtig ohne jetzt diese Drohung
auszusprechen jetzt noch mal ein neues
Kapitel mit der Türkei zu öffnen wichtig
ist natürlich die Augenhöhe wie man mit
der Türkei redet wer leitet kann ich gut
verstehen es wenn es offen und sagt ich
möchte nicht dass der Türkei vor der
Mitglied weil es mitgeliebte
Europäischen Union wird das muss man
auch gesagt werden aber wirklich auf der
gleichen Augenhöhe mit der Türkei und
dann müssen auch die Verhältnisse
geklärt werden ja wenn kein
Mitgliedschaft welches Verhältnis wollen
wir denn mit der Türkei was bedeutet
dieser privilegierte
Mitgliedschaft das sind sehr viele
Fragen offen da habe ich den Eindruck
dass beide nicht mit offenen Karten
spielen ich werde Europäische Union noch
die Türkei und dann geht es immer darum
um was verhandelt wird jetzt geht es
konkret um die NATO-Mitgliedschaft
Schweden wo die Türkei ja dem nicht
zustimmt er hatte man ja gehofft dass
das jetzt funktioniert einmal und dann
das andere ist natürlich dass der Erde
an diese diese Zug hat in der Hand mit
den flüchtlingsabkommen dass er sagen
kann wenn dann lasse ich einfach die
Türen mache ich die Türen auf und dann
kommen alle Flüchtlinge zu euch und da
ist natürlich ein große große Angst in
Europa als auf diese Ebene darf kein
Verhältnis zwischen der Türkei umgeben
aber ist ja gerade im Moment also im
Moment hat man das Gefühl der wird so
wird dann irgendwie fast gehandelt also
Finnland dem stört man zu den hatte
Mitgliedschaft Schweden aber nicht und
dann kann man vielleicht noch mal die
Preise hochtreiben
vielleicht kurz zu den
flüchtlingsabkommen also es wurde immer
wieder damit gedroht dass der Deal
platzen wird er es nie geplatzt das muss
man konsortieren aber zur NATO das nehme
ich ein wichtiger Punkt und der war im
übrigen auch Wahl entscheidend für viele
Wählerinnen und Wähler bei Finnland hat
man geklärt werden gemacht warum hat man
sie gemacht weil nämlich die ureigenen
Sicherheitsinteressen der Türkei berührt
waren was die Bekämpfung des
international Terrorismus anbelangt die
Türkei hat ein großes Problem mit der
Bekämpfung des Terror insbesondere des
pkk-karte heraus Schweden macht
keinerlei Zugeständnis und da sagt die
Türkei als NATO Mitglied ich habe dieses
Virtu Recht und wenn meine ureigensten
Sicherheitsbedürfnisse wenn denen nicht
entsprochen wird dann werde ich auch von
meinem Veto Recht Gebrauch machen und
ich glaube da werden sie mir
wahrscheinlich zustimmen dass der Herr
König oder ein großen Fehler gemacht hat
zumindest beim ersten bei der ersten
Runde der Wahlen er hat nämlich die
Frage des Terrors die hat ja
unterschätzt es gab viele Bekundungen
von
pkk-führern die gesagt haben wird so er
hat denen nicht vehement widersprochen
und das haben ihm die Wähler übel
genommen und in der zweiten Warnung hat
er versucht das irgendwie zu kitten das
hat aber dann nicht mehr gereicht für
uns wie wichtig oder wie sehr braucht
die NATO die Türkei und wie viel muss
man davon dann abhängig machen wie viel
Zugeständnis kannst dann da geben also
ich kann mir eine NATO ohne die Türkei
und ohne die Stärke der Türkei alleine
schon geopolitisch wo sie ist gar nicht
vorstellen oder ich mag sie mir gar
nicht vorstellen und
was die
in dem Zusammenhang das Verhältnis zu
Russland betrifft wo sehr genau beachtet
werden die Türkei hat eine unglaublich
wichtige Rolle in der NATO wenn vor
allem wenn wir uns vorstellen sie wäre
nicht Mitglied der NATO was dann
passieren würde sie würde sage ich mal
in die Arme von von Putin dem
Kriegstreiber der die Ukraine überfallen
hat und weiter überfällt getrieben
werden können sie würde sich weiter nach
Osten orientieren und dann hätten wir
eine eine wichtige Schaltstelle ist also
die Türkei zu Syrien oder jetzt auch wie
es angesprochen wurde in der Vermittlung
im Ukraine Krieg war was das
getreideabkommen betraf uns würde da
viel fehlen und auf der anderen Seite
fanden finde ich weiterhin den Prozess
der Aufnahme Schwedens in die NATO auch
ein ein wie ich finde nicht ein
Druckmittel was nicht in Ordnung ist wie
Erdogan ist ansetzt was
auch nicht verhältnismäßig ist aus
meiner Sicht Schweden vorzuwerfen
PKK Terror zu dulden oder eben nicht die
Türkei davon nicht zu schützen das hat
natürlich Herrn Erdogan im Wahlkampf
auch sehr geholfen so wie es dem
Herausforderer geschadet hat hat es ihm
auch sehr geholfen
womit rechnen Sie Herr Laschet wird die
Türkei jetzt zustimmen das weiß jetzt im
Wahlkampf war es nützlich jetzt ist der
Wahlkampf die Wahl gewonnen was wie
rechnen Sie jetzt damit wie er dann
jetzt entscheidet das Schweden dann doch
mitglied werden kann
also
das weiß man ja bei Hannover nie genau
wohin das geht er hat in der Tat in
seiner Region den außenpolitischen Kurs
in den letzten Jahren verändert ich
finde zum Guten verändert zum
konstruktiven Verändern der hat jangel
lange Jahre lang überall Muslim
Bruderschaften unterstützt in Ägypten
und anderswo er hat den Präsidenten
Perez aus Israel beleidigt dann waren
die Beziehungen eingefroren jetzt gibt
es wieder Beziehungen zu Israel er ist
konstruktiv aktiv rund um die
Golfstaaten also er ist sich seiner
neuen Rolle bewusst und auch merkt dass
ihm die nutzt und ich würde die
Vermutung äußern das Schweden in der Tat
in den nächsten Wochen sagen wird dass
sie einen anderen Umgang zu manchen
pkk-gruppen in Schweden finden werden
und das dann Präsident Erdogan
spätestens beim Gipfel in willius im
Juli eine Aufnahme Schwedens zustimmt
die Kernfrage wäre in der Wahlanalyse
natürlich auch gewesen
ja bitte welche Position hätte
eigentlich die Opposition wahrgenommen
wenn sie gewonnen hätte ich würde mal
sagen wir suchen ja mal Adjektive für
die jeweiligen Parteien
religiös
nationalistisch wird Erdogan beschrieben
aber
säkular-nationalistisch kann man auch
die Opposition beschreiben gegenüber den
Kurden verfolgt sie im Prinzip einen
sehr großen Kurs das war immer die Linie
der Kemalisten Erdogan selbst hat am
Anfang seiner Amtszeit sogar die
kurdische Sprache zugelassen hat
Christen die Möglichkeit gegeben da ihre
Religion besser auszuüben das ist im
Laufe der Zeit etwas schwieriger
geworden Kemalisten waren da immer sehr
groß und interessant fand ich das bei
dem russischen Wahlergebnis also der
Türken die in Russland leben
56% für die Opposition gestimmt haben
also wie der außenpolitische Kurs
geworden wäre hätte die Opposition
gewonnen
das wäre jedenfalls nicht so eindeutig
total an der Seite des Westens wie das
bei uns manche glauben und hätte dann
auch ein sehr differenziertes Bild
gegeben in der Schweden nato-frage wäre
es wahrscheinlich sehr ähnlich gewesen
und abschließend nochmal zusammengefasst
ich glaube dass in den nächsten Wochen
wir erleben werden das auch Schweden mit
deternato werden kann und die Türkei
zustimmt sehen Sie es auch so also dass
die dass sie damit rechnen dass Schweden
Mitglied wird und jetzt vielleicht auch
noch mal einen Punkt zur Opposition weil
der Kredit ja sehr stark dann gesagt hat
er will alle Flüchtlinge aus dem Land
schicken also was hätte sich was was
wäre eigentlich besser gewesen wenn
Erdogan jetzt nicht gewonnen hätte
weiß dass er so ein Pragmatiker ist und
für ihn ist so ein wahlentscheidend
nicht unbedingt Politik entscheidend ist
und der hat die Wahl jetzt auch mit den
Aussagen gegenüber Schweden für sich
entschieden und der wird jetzt natürlich
ein anderen Kurs weil er ganz selber
auch ganz genau weiß dass er auch sehr
viel davon hat dass sie weiterhin in
NATO bleibt deswegen wieder hier eine
pragmatische Lösung finden und der wird
dann natürlich auch so im Rahmen für die
türkische Bevölkerung dass das dass man
ihn zustimmt und das andere was was kann
ich darüber in seinem zweiten Periode
gesagt hat die Wahl war in der Türkei
natürlich sehr emotionalisiert und das
was ich am Anfang gesagt habe diese
ganze fähig nie Videos und gekriegt
darüber immer mit Terror in Verbindung
zu bringen und dass er sogar soweit geht
dass er ein Stück von Türkei der PKK
abgegeben hat es waren Sprüche auch aus
der Regierung und dass er dem
widersetzen wollte aus meiner nicht auch
mit unglücklichen unglücklicher
politischen Stil die Art von von einer
Partei übernommen hat die sich erwähnend
gegen Flüchtlinge in der Türkei
geschossen hat aber man muss auch da
bisschen differenziert differenzieren
zwischen Flüchtlingspolitik in der
Türkei und Flüchtlingspolitik in
Deutschland und das sieht die Situation
in der Türkei etwas anders aus dennoch
darf man natürlich über Menschen nicht
so reden auch wenn man sagt wir werden
Sie innerhalb von zwei Jahren freundlich
mit Musik nach Syrien
liefern das geht nicht man verhandelt
über die Menschen das war aus meiner
Sicht auch sehr sehr unglücklich aber
wie gesagt
möchte ich dann natürlich widersprechen
was die Kurden Frage angeht ich kann
zustimmen was der Erdogan in
der ersten vier Jahre in der Türkei
gemacht hat jetzt der hat nicht nur
Kurden Frage angesprochen der hat auch
das Militär als end Digitalisierung
angesprochen der hat viele Themen
aufgegriffen von den er aber Stück ob
für Stück immer wieder verabschiedet hat
inzwischen hat er sich zwar hat er die
Türkei entbilitisiert aber die Türkei
ist inzwischen wie ein parteistaat
geworden also das darf man nicht außer
Acht lassen also wie gesagt für die
Menschen die die Türkei in EU nicht
wollen hat sich die Türkei positiv
entwickelt aber das ist nicht unbedingt
etwas was ich mir wünsche sagen wir mal
auf die nächsten fünf Jahre die da
kommen ja sehen weil der Wirtschaft geht
das schlechte Lehrer wurde jetzt auch
noch mal stark abgewehrt es gibt eine
hohe Inflation es gab große Probleme
nach dem Erdbeben also das sind ja alles
keine positiven Nachrichten es gibt wie
gesagt was wir vorhin schon gesagt haben
keine Pressefreiheit all das was womit
rechnen sie denn jetzt wie sich dieses
ja wie die Türkei sich jetzt entwickelt
die Türkei wird natürlich diese
wirtschaftlichen Fragen angehen müssen
aber auch hier muss man konstatieren
dass alibabajan das war ja einer der in
diesem Sechser Tisch saß er war mal
Wirtschaftsminister und ihm wurde
sozusagen zugetraut dass er das
Verändern kannte aber die Leute haben
nicht diesen Sechser Bündnis Glauben
geschenkt sondern Herrn Erdogan weil man
nämlich davon ausgegangen ist dass er
die Türkei durch diese turbulenten
Zeiten durch das sichere Fahrwasser
führen kann und geleiten kann und ich
glaube das ist jetzt auch genau dieser
Punkt der angegangen wird das heißt die
Türkei wird Kontinuität zeigen was die
politischen Maßstäbe anbelangt und was
die wirtschaftspolitischen Belange
angeht da gibt es auch Akzente die auch
während des Wahlkampfes zum Ausdruck
gekommen sind beispielsweise der
ehemalige Minister schimzecheck er wurde
das öfteren genannt während des
Wahlkampfes ob er denn zurückkommen
würde er hat eine große Bank geleitet
eine große angesetzte Bank und man
relativ schnell klar möchte nicht
Wirtschaftspolitik ja in der Tat aber
man weiß jetzt er wird nicht in die
Perspektive Politik zurückkehren
voraussichtlich nicht zurückkehren aber
wird beraten beiseite stehen das heißt
all diese Punkte die wird Herr Erdogan
selbstbewusst angehen und zurück noch
mal zur NATO Mitgliedschaft Schwedens es
ist nicht so dass das jetzt ein
innenpolitisches Thema war
außenpolitisches Thema was in politisch
genutzt werden wird wenn Schweden keine
sicherheitsgestell Zugeständnisse macht
wird Erdogan bei seinem Punkt bleiben
und bei seinem Veto bleiben das muss man
klar konzentrieren
mit was rechnen Sie in der Türkei
eine kleine
in der Analyse stimmt der letzte Satz
aber um wirtschaftlich jetzt auf die
Beine zu kommen bei dem Zustand der
türkischen Wirtschaft ist Erdogan
natürlich auf den Westen angewiesen
und insofern spielt das auch eine Rolle
bei der schwedenfrage die schwedenfrage
wird nicht ganz so theoretisch wie wir
das jetzt hier besprechen
und andere westliche Länder werden auch
für weitere Wirtschaftshilfe die
Erwartungen aussprechen das hier eine
klare Haltung zu dieser
NATO-Mitgliedschaft Schweden kommt so
dass ich glaube dass Erde waren jetzt
eher sich auch Richtung Westen bewegt im
eigenen Interesse um die wirtschaftliche
Krise zu überwinden
was ist ihre Erwartung und wie könnte
man sozusagen von EU von Deutschland das
auch Stützen also wenn ich die
Wahlsieg Rede von Herrn Erdogan richtig
verstanden habe hat er keine
versöhnungsrede gehalten er hat nicht
die Arme ausgebreitet und außer dass die
tat was sie gebracht hatten wir haben
gewonnen aber man erinnert sich an das
eine Zitat eines seiner Minister wie
werden die Opposition vernichten und wir
werden zusammen bleiben bis ins Grab
woraus man jetzt befürchten kann er wird
er plant nicht nur für die nächsten fünf
Jahre dann wäre seine Amtszeit definitiv
zu Ende nachdem er sich vorher eine
unglaublich lange Amtszeit verschafft
hat durch die Verfassungsänderung und
die Signale waren für mich nicht so dass
er das Land eint oder einen will sondern
dass er sage ich noch mal so als Schock
das ist so knapp war obwohl der
Wahlkampf so gelaufen ist wie er
gelaufen ist trotzdem so knapp war
versuchen wird seine Macht politisch zu
manifestieren mit auch mit brachialen
Methoden und außenpolitisch denke ich
das was Herr Laschet sagt dass
wirtschaftlich gesehen er wird sich sehr
nach Russland orientieren können alles
was die Energie betrifft wenn wir nicht
die Hand reichen das müssen wir das
werden noch ganz wichtig dass wir
sozusagen versuchen dass die Nähe zu
Russland nicht stärker wird durch eine
kleine Anmerkung war das schon mehrmals
gefallen ist weil er die Wahl knapp
gewonnen hat wird immer gesagt die
letzten Mal hat er mit 51,8% gewonnen
das heißt es war noch knapp also diese
Wahl also so das Argument das verfängt
ein klein wenig wenn man sagt er hat die
Wahl knapp gewonnen das stimmt nicht es
sind zweieinhalb Millionen Stimmen
Unterschied das muss man auch sehen dann
mach mal ganz kurz noch die den Punkt
Russland ja also wie schafft man das
dass man ja dass die Türkei nicht zu nah
an Russland kommt
das wird man wahrscheinlich nicht
schaffen wenn man nicht ehrlich mit der
Türkei umgeht deswegen
ist glaube wir müssen uns davon
distanzieren dass man die Türkei ist von
Erdogan bestehend sieht ich habe das
Gefühl dass Europa
die Türkei wirklich seit längerer Zeit
aus Erdogan bestehen sieht so wie man
jetzt gerade die
türkische Wähler und Wählern die AKP
gewählt haben das über die der ganze
ganze türkische Community in Deutschland
diskutiert wird den Fehler dürfen wir
natürlich nicht machen deswegen muss
Europa Zugeständnisse machen der Türkei
gegenüber muss die Türkei sich bewegen
Richtung Europa
und man freut sich natürlich auch über
dieses ganze Verhältnis zwischen Türkei
und Russland auch in Europa wegen dieser
ganze Getreide Abkommen und so weiter
man muss man muss einfach wirklich
gegenüber
sein also da seid ihr wichtig hier aber
das sollte dir die Klappe halten das
geht natürlich nicht ja lass es ganz
kurz noch
30 Sekunden so Türkei und Russland gibt
es einen Punkt wo sie sagen da brauchen
da und da müssen wir besonders aufpassen
dass die Türkei nicht näher an Russland
kommt generell ist meine generelle
Bemerkung zur Außenpolitik der Rest der
Welt sieht die Dinge anders als wir
China Indien Türkei Israel arabische
Welt große Teile Afrikas der Präsident
von Brasilien die sehen das alles anders
als wir und dann muss man überzeugen und
Argumente finden und darf dann in der
Außenpolitik nicht vor allem andere
belehren das ist mein Kritikpunkt an dem
wie wir im Moment mit vielen Partnern
umgehen und insofern müssen wir ihn da
gewinnen ihn in seiner vermittlungsrolle
Stärken und ihm vor allem klarmachen
verdunst hat das ein paar mal gesagt
dass er im Westen einen Platz hat und
nicht nach Russland ableitet aber das
geht nicht mit Belehrung sondern mit
konkreten Angeboten in der Politik okay
vielen Dank Herr Laschet vielen Dank für
Sofi Frau Dunst für diese Diskussion wir
haben ein bisschen überzogen und jetzt
kommt Phoenix der Tag mit Konstanz ich
darf mich hier aber bedanken für die
Diskussion die so sagten bei der Herren
eigentlich in der Türkei gar nicht so
möglich wäre dass jemand von der AKP und
Opposition hier so miteinander
diskutieren also haben wir einen guten
Anfang gemacht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]